[Music]
in this video we will showcase the most
powerful robots from different movie
franchises and universes we are going to
take only one from each the most
powerful and arrange it in a super list
that will rank them with the most
powerful would compare with the other
universes each robot will be a
representative from their own universe
and will be ranked in terms of how
powerful they are in comparison to other
entries from other universes so let us
get down with this sickness
number 15 from the terminator universe
the t5000 seen in the movie terminator
genesis skynet's greatest and most
powerful creation is the t5000
which also houses the core software of
the ai itself since the only known d5000
unit so far was only seen briefly in
terminator genesis its combat abilities
are largely unknown the t5000 possesses
the ability to infect human beings with
nanorobots which can recode the human
dna at a cellular level transforming
them into t3000 cyborgs
number 14 from the star wars universe
the nk necrosis from this universe most
of the robots in cyborgs are
collectively called as droids and so we
will bring in the most powerful one and
this is the nk necrosis which is also
the template
and which was created from the body of
general grievous himself this droid has
excellent shooting skills and even
impressive melee combat performance
including fighting with lightsabers it
only lacks the access to the dark side
of the force to be at par with the jedi
and a sith at number 13 from the doctor
who universe the cyber king
so from doctor who comes a dreadnought
class ship whose pilot was integrated
into it making it the cyber king it was
a huge bipedal robot operated by the
living controller these ships were used
to front a cyberman invasion by
crippling whole cities and upgrading
their population and mars
they were the largest if not the most
powerful weapons utilized by the
cybermen in battle nevertheless it was
one of the most powerful in its universe
aside from the daleks
number 12 from the incredibles the
omnidroid version 10. well the
omnidroids are a secondary antagonist
from the incredibles and they are a
series of superhero killing battle
robots created by the super villain
syndrome as part of operation chronos
omnidroid version 10 is the final
omnidroid created by syndrome it is the
largest strongest and seemingly smartest
of the omnidroids the android version 10
is 5 stories tall making it the largest
and can even fight mr incredible to a
stalemate
number 11 from the power rangers
universe we have the megazord this
megazord this robot is referred to as a
dino megazord and is the mighty
combination form of five dinosaurs the
tyrannosaurus mastodon triceratops the
saber-tooth tiger and the pterodactyl
coming from the power rangers this
combined form of all the zords is the
most powerful robot of that universe and
it can be seen in either its tank form
or its battle mode both of which are
extremely powerful
number 10 from the pacific rim we have
gypsy avenger coming from the world of
the kaiju and the giant robot makers
called jaegers the most powerful from
this universe is obviously the one that
sacrificed itself to kill the mega kaiju
and this is gypsy avenger it was built
in honor of gypsy danger and designed
using its design template standing 268
feet tall this giant mecca has swords
can fly can fire a gravity sling and
when the time comes like its predecessor
can self-detonate its nuclear power unit
number nine from the day the earth stood
still g-o-r-t or god
from the sci-fi movie the ddl stood
still humanity was confronted by an
alien who came to seek how humanity was
doing along with his robot bodyguard
which was called god in the 2008 remake
this god was made of tiny nanobots that
are impervious to any weaponry of man
and can eat through anything metal and
besides that it can also disarm and
deactivate any weapon system that is
aimed at it
number 8 the iron giant the iron giant
he is a whopping 50 foot tall autonomous
metal man from another world that crash
landed on earth before becoming friends
with a young boy named hoggart who
rescues him from his own internal
defensive mechanisms
the iron giant has very advanced
weaponry which can vaporize and destroy
anything that humans point at it
moreover it can survive a nuclear weapon
detonation and although it was blown to
bits the constituent parts can
reassemble over time making it near
invincible if you think about it and it
was sent to earth in the first place to
destroy all human life
number seven from the mcu we have vision
well vision was a synthazoid made from
vibranium created by ultron with the
help of helen cho and given life by the
powerful artifact known as the mind
stone an infinity stone originally
conceived as the perfect form of ultron
vision has superhuman strength and
durability can face in and out of matter
he could shoot energy beams manipulate
the density of matter fly and control
the internet and moreover he can wield
the hammer mjolnir as he is worthy but
that depends on thor if he is willing to
share the weapon with vision
number six from gundam the zero zero
quantity gundam technically a mecca
gundam is one of the most notable of the
japanese cartoon robots alongside
evangelion gundam has had many versions
and the most powerful of them is the
double o quantity of gundam a 5th
generation design for a celestial to
pilot it its main weapon is the gn sword
v which can be used both as a blade and
a powerful rifle it can use a teleport
technique and also has a shield for
defense it is the eptomy of martial arts
makers
number five from toho from the godzilla
universe we have mecha godzilla this is
yet another japanese creation it is
humanity's answer to godzilla and was
made to look like the king of the
monsters himself but glad in metal it
has had many versions from its first
appearance in the 1974 movie but monster
vs incarnation takes the crown of the
most powerful version of it from that
universe of legendary it can defeat a
godzilla that has enough power to drill
a hole to the center of the earth
imagine that it can only be taken down
by a forced alliance of kong and the big
g
number 4 we have star trek and it's
representative the ball collective no we
are not going to put in a single
individual ball as it's not really
impressive but the bulk collective as a
whole well the collective makes
decisions as a single entity that's why
we are going to put it as a single entry
although the single individual bulk
isn't that intimidating a group of them
can be very scary but the collective as
a whole rules a quarter of the milky way
galaxy and it takes the romulans the
klingons and even the federation to ally
with one another in order to even stand
a chance in fighting the book it can
absorb and learn from every species it
assimilates and at the same time
developing weapons and countermeasures
for weapons rapidly even in the midst of
the battle
number three from the transformers
universe we have unicron
before the dawn of time he is known as
the bringer of chaos the lord of the
undead and one of the main sources of
evil in the entire universe and the very
source of dark energon itself as an
immortal and an eternal being with
immense power unicron is the eternal
arch enemy of his twin brother primus
the creator of the transformer race
unicron is definitely one of the most
powerful on the list and can only be
topped by these other two check them out
at the second spot we have from the
dragon ball universe super perfect cell
yeah this is a surprising entry it is
one of the main villains of the famous
japanese anime dragon ball z this
android was created in order to achieve
perfection and had to consume a couple
of other androids to get there and once
it did it was powerful enough to destroy
planets without breaking a sweat
cell has an original personality
engineered by gero's computer to combine
the character traits of his genetic
constituents which would be most useful
for a perfect weapon
and top spot from gurren lagann universe
we have super topper tangent gorilla gan
a super tangent topper guru nagan the
most powerful robot on this list is the
one that is bigger than the universe
itself the super tangent topper guren
lagann contains the mass of the infinity
big bang storm which in itself has a
power on power the birth of the entire
multiverse so
that's a lot to take in sdtgl
speed can be practically uncalculable
due to the lack of reference frames so
yeah the number one spot goes to this
overpowered oversized and over
everything colossal mecca like mass of
energy and so with that we come to the
end of this video do hit that like
button for support and don't forget to
subscribe to be a part of our mind cue
family till the next one take care fam